hey guys i'm roxy diaz and i'm free
marie
and i'm freddy and welcome to cocoa
butter's voting special
the purpose of this show is to give each
so what we're going to do is we're going
to touch on some really important issues
that affects us both
locally and on a national level
but before we get started what i want to
know is how
amped up and ready are you guys for all
that we have in store for everybody
[Music]
[Laughter]
if i see people doing that dance at the
voter live i'm gonna crack
up i'm super excited in a vote i have
a mail-in voter registration and i can
do the other way so i'm ready either way
but i think i'm gonna go out
and do it because i want to be there
with the people i feel the energy
absolutely i'm super excited to vote i
vote
every election that comes around so this
is no different but 2020 is a whole
different beast
so we all have to get out there and i'm
excited to get our audience informed
yeah i am just with you guys too except
i will be home
filling in my ballot and kind of making
it like a pop quiz googling everybody
and then filling it out at the same time
so
that's gonna be my strategy but we're
gonna teach everybody
about different strategies and what they
could do but first inform them free
that's right in case you've been living
under a rock somewhere and don't know
what's going on it's time for us to
inform you
on the republican side we have donald
trump and mike
pence their policies include clean
energy
protecting the right to bear arms and
limiting international interference
and on the democratic side is joe biden
and kamala harris their policies include
universal child care closing the racial
wealth gap and more jobs for americans
we pretty much know what these
candidates stand for but we're really
here to get to the bottom
of what black and brown people need on
the micro level
that's right because what we're really
looking for is a better employment
accessible healthcare and for
latinos especially we're looking for
immigration right not just latinos but
immigrants in this country and i'm so
glad
that i have my friend the founder of
shisepoile
and also this is about humanity elsa
collins is joining us
right now to talk about black and brown
communities and
immigration rights i'm so excited
because this woman is so powerful
and so informative when i heard that we
were having this series i was like elsa
i need elsa right now so thank you so
much for joining us elsa
thank you for having me so tell us a
little bit about both your organizations
yeah amazing so i'm one of the
co-founders of shisepoede which is a new
digital lifestyle community founded by
10 amazing latinas including america
ferreira and eva longoria
jess morales monica ramirez stephanie
valencia christie hubbard alex
drakki there are 10 of us involved and
we really
came together and started looking around
at our community and said
what is out there for us that speaks to
our needs our desires our wishes um
and fully embraces who we can be as a
community
so that's really where shise puede was
born
and we're so excited to be
in existence we're excited for people to
be a part of this community like you
roxy thank you so much
and really we're looking to empower
latinas not just in our household
but also in the community and to be
civically engaged
so can you tell us about this is about
humanity and what policy changes
that your organization can benefit from
yeah so this is about humanity i'm one
of the co-founders of we
um were founded in 2018 in response to
the family separation crisis
we were all seeing what everyone was
seeing these children being separated
from their parents
hearing the recordings of them crying
out for mama
it was a visceral reaction that i think
all of us had
um i grew up on the border so i have a
personal connection to what's happening
and um you know we just wanted to
respond to raise awareness
about the issue so that people could
feel more comfortable talking about it a
lot of times when
people talk about immigration or family
separation they feel like it's
it's complicated they're not really sure
what's going on and so
they don't feel comfortable speaking out
or speaking up on the issue
um so that's really what this is about
humanity is uh has its mission
and clearly what we would benefit from
is policies and decisions that respect
the laws of asylum that have existed in
this country for many years
so slowly we have been peeling back
the ability to seek asylum which is a
it's a human right to seek asylum
um a lot of times people say like is
that really the right way to come into
this country
but you know seeking asylum is one of
those ways and so we want to make sure
that we're
respecting asylum laws um and that we're
protecting
uh individuals who are seeking refuge
yeah so we love the work that you all
are doing to make sure that
people seeking asylum are protected you
know so like sort of along those lines
i'd love to chat with you to find out
like are there voters right for
undocumented residents
so people who are undocumented in this
country unfortunately don't have a right
to vote
so i want to encourage everybody who
does have a right to vote
to think about what that really means
and to vote for those who can't in this
country
so i'm relying on everyone who cares
about our undocumented brothers and
sisters
our dreamers our daca brothers and
sisters to really vote on their behalf
so that we can make sure that we're
protecting them and that we
are putting people in positions of power
who
have an idea about how to have a path to
citizenship
how to make positive immigration reform
in this country
so i think that's the message i want
everyone to walk away with
is if you're sort of on the fence about
voting because you don't think that your
life is going to change either way
know that it someone else's life is
going to change in a big way
and i wanted to follow up with that i
know what she said whether in your
organizations we do focus a lot on
latin immigration but it is
all immigration in this country i always
tell the story of how
i came to this country as an immigrant
and when i did seek my citizenship when
i got sworn in
it wasn't just latinos it's asians
african
indonesians caribbean so when you think
about
who you're voting for and even though
you may have the right but that next
person doesn't what kind of things do
you like to arm
voters with before they go on the poll
one of my favorite things that you say
is if you have a take-home test take it
home and study it and fill it in
while you're while you're voting um
think about an election
as a job performance review you know we
all get
job performance reviews and when you do
well you get a thumbs up and when you
don't do well
well some not good things happen so an
election
is an opportunity to give a performance
review for those
that are in power so we want to make
sure that we're studying and we know the
issues we know how they voted we know
their positions on the things that
matter to
us because we're about to give them a
job review
we love you we love your organization
and keep on fighting for us
girl power we love it thank you every
year is important
but this is one of the most important
times to vote in our
lifetime between the pandemic the
ongoing protest
and the dependence things are at an
all-time high the murders of george
floyd brianna taylor and ahmad aubry
were clearly a call for immediate police
reform
absolutely free and our next guest is
using this power to enact change
you know him from amazon's if you know
the boys please welcome laz alonso liz
thank you so much for being here
my pleasure thank you for having me how
y'all doing
we're good freddy that's the last hey
less
all right all right um okay so how are
you
how are you using your celebrity to help
push forward the afro-latino november
uh so you know i really don't look at it
as using celebrity um
i feel like it's really about using
humanity
i happen to have a platform i happen to
have a group of people that have
supported my career
from day one and so now when the tables
are turned
and they need support because there are
injustices happening all around us um
it will behoove me to do the same that
they have done for me for all these
years because i wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for
a very loyal fan base that's been there
with me through my highs and my lows
so uh how do i use it to amplify their
voices
you know i'm not on the front lines
there are other people who live this
battle
every single day and i feel like as a
quote unquote
celebrity it would be disingenuous to
try to step on out in the front lines
and grab a megaphone
and try to act like this is my fight no
this is our
fight and there are leaders that are
doing this morning
tonight who are educated with the
day-to-day
battles that they're facing representing
the community and its activism
and it's up to us to use our platform to
amplify
their voices not try to come in and and
because i'm a celebrity now
let me just come up with something and
and wing it that's not how i work right
and there's one thing that i know about
you liz is you're
a huge news buff you're always watching
the news you're always staying up to
date with what's going on in the world
and what i'm curious to know
with everything that we see in the news
and with covet we see so much police
brutality
how much do you think that's actually
going to affect
people going out to the polls and voting
and just voting in general especially
our black and brown community
so i've gotten off the news rocks uh to
a certain degree
i've come i've you know downgraded the
amount of news that i consumed
by over 50 percent um and i've been
investing that time
into talking to people and spending
one-on-one time trying to get people to
become politically active
to register to vote to check to make
sure they're registered to vote and to
go out and vote
um the problem that i'm finding is that
there
are very very well-paid
uh people who look like us
uh that are designed to their main
objective is to make us feel
disenfranchised and like our votes do
not matter
no matter who you vote for or who matter
who gets elected
it won't make a difference in your life
and that is simply false that is
that is fake um and it's unfortunate
because
they are very well trained very
convincing and very well financed
and if if voting didn't make a change
and didn't matter
then why would they be spending so much
time and effort and money to get us not
to vote
ultimately the system needs to be
changed and the only way that is going
to change is from the inside
out we can protest to we're blue in the
face
and it is a very effective way to bring
attention to a situation
but once you bring the attention to the
situation you need the right people
on the inside to carry out and create
policy and then enforce policy because
it ain't enough just to create policy
you have to make sure that the people
that are on the inside
enforce it you know we look at the case
with brianna taylor
and a lot of new information is coming
out now
and we realize that a lot of what we
heard that attorney general say
was just simply not true and if we don't
have the right people on the inside
that are going to enforce policy with a
certain level of humanity in mind
then then we're basically giving up
what do you do how do you choose and how
do you consider a candidate that speaks
to you
and what's your process when when it
comes to voting
i mean that's a good choice that's a
good question because
um there are so many people on the state
and local level
um that i still have my homework to do
before november 3rd so
admittedly i have work to do uh between
now and then
you know still even though i already
know when it comes to voting
uh in the general election for president
uh who are
who i'm gonna vote for when it comes to
all the other
state and local people i have to do my
homework
uh i have to do my research you know and
and look them up and find out what
articles have been written about
them and what kind of voting records
they have what kind of moves they have
um because like you know there's a
saying that says all skin folk ain't
kinfolk
you know so you got to make sure that
the person that you're voting for
speaks directly to the things that you
want um
and out of life thank you last and
everybody that's a fan of last be sure
you check him out
on amazon the boys that is out he's
doing
phenomenal work on that so we are back
at it again to make sure
you're as informed as possible for
november 3rd we have so much information
for you
and we have some more guests to talk but
before we do here are some quick facts
that you should know
the 15th amendment gave black men the
right to vote
the 19th amendment gave women the right
to vote excluding women of color
and did you know that the civil rights
act of 1964 gave us
universal voting rights and just because
we are
legally able to vote it doesn't mean
that we don't face other challenges
activists and author mark lamont hill is
here to talk about challenges like voter
suppression and what it looks like
mark thank you so much for joining us oh
it's my pleasure good to see you yes
with the hoodie
good to see you mark you too let's talk
about voter suppression can you give us
some examples of what voter suppression
can look like
yeah i mean basically voter suppression
is an attempt to take people
who should be voting and stopping them
from voting
and so voting suppression can look like
um
not having enough machines at the polls
uh it could be having uh
not the right language uh uh signs up in
the neighborhood for example if there's
a neighborhood where
everyone speaks spanish as a first
language or as a primary language
or if i'm in dearborn michigan where
everyone speaks arabic as a
or a lot of people speak arabic as a
primary language and all the signs
are in are in english it might make it
harder to find the polls or get the man
or read
what's mailed to me um voter id laws are
one of the primary ways though
uh that we see voter suppression making
people have demanding that people have
certain types of ids
when they come to the polls will lower
the chances that poor people
uh that that very very old people
and others have access to the polls
because they may not have the resources
necessary to get an id because a whole
bunch of folk
who may work legal jobs who work really
hard may not be able to get a state id
why do you think voter depression
happens more in black and brown
communities
because quite honestly if everybody
voted i'm not even talking
just if everybody voted the elections
would turn out probably the same way
every election cycle
and so a lot of times uh particular
people in power particular parties
i don't get two partisans i know we're
talking about voting right now not
politics per se but but a lot of times
the question becomes how does a party
win when they don't have the most votes
well a lot of times if they win because
all the people who can vote don't vote
and so what the powerful often do
regardless of their political party is
try to create rules
or situations that that discourage
people from voting
and so then so then the numbers get
lower and lower and lower
um and so i mean imagine if i was on a
call with you three right now
and i said well i'm gonna i want us to
vote on some policies and i want to make
policies so that men run everything it's
three of y'all in one of me
so i'm not gonna win those votes but if
i start making new voting rules like
only people with hoodies can vote
right only people who work that bet
could vote i could
i could cut like three people i could
cut at least one person right there
right and i keep making rules
that and it's the law and then i might
be able to get it so that it's one to
one or two to one i might be able to
convince roxy to come on my side and
convince free to come on my side right
and so that would be the logic and
that's what we see it you know
parties don't win by the majority of
votes they win by the margin of people
who don't have access to the vote got it
you know
and i want you to really really explain
to people mark what is the difference
between voter suppression
and voter fraud because a lot of they
they skew that line
and i saw your vain popping out when you
was ready to choose a party and talk
about bipartisan stuff
that we're not supposed to talk about
see i follow the rules i'm mad but i'm
gonna follow the rules
thank you thank you you know
so i said i said voter suppression is um
processes and laws that take people who
could or should be voting
and making it harder for them to vote
voter fraud is people who should not be
voting
and creating processes and laws or not
laws necessary but processes
that make it that allow them to vote for
example
um my uncle bobby he died in 1994.
if he were to vote that would be voter
fraud because he can't vote
but we've seen the states where people
who are who are dead have somehow
managed to get on a voter on a voter
roll
uh if i if i vote twice that would be
voted fraud
if i'm 16 and i vote that would be voter
fraud
voter fraud is often the excuse that
people use to justify voter suppression
right so they say
well we don't want anybody to to show up
and vote wrong we don't want it we don't
want anybody to show up and
and be fake at the polls so we're going
to make all these rules and laws that
make it harder to get to the polls
that's why you need an id
and that's the argument that some people
will make they'll say well you need an
id to get in the club
so if you need an idea to get in the
club why wouldn't you need an id to vote
and the answer to that question like i
think it's an important question
is i don't have a constitutional right
to go to magic city or or whatever club
right i don't have a constitutional
right
to to to to do certain activities i have
a constitutional right to vote
and the 24th amendment just to give you
one example the 24th amendment
makes it illegal to have a poll tax
the reason it's illegal to have a poll
tax is because if i
if i make people have to pay a tax at
the voting booth then what i'm doing is
i'm making it harder for poor people to
vote and easier for rich people to vote
which will skew an election it
undermines democracy
well if if you need a if i need an id to
vote
and i say well you just need an id
everybody need an id
but how do i get an id why i need the
social security off i need my social
security card and my purchasing
how do i get that i got to get in the
car got to drive to the office got to
fill out this stuff got to write a check
got to mail it out got to have an
address to get it to
that becomes a poll tax in its own way
because i'm having to spend money to do
something to vote
and so that's why um these voted the
voter fraud and voter suppression
conversation is so important nobody
wants voter fraud
but we don't want to create rules that
is so intense that they actually lead
to suppression and let me be real clear
about this voter fraud happens very very
rarely
in comparison to voter suppression
people do not
lose and win elections because of voter
fraud they lose and win elections
because of because of voter suppression
you have a better
voter the odds of voter fraud are so
minimal you have a better chance
of winning a presidency but by voter
fraud you have a better chance of of
winning
uh winning the powerball you know a
better chance of of
of winning a house and publishers
clearing clearinghouse i mean the odds
are so small
whereas with voter suppression we see it
all the time
um what one last thing because this is
something that people need to think
about when they vote this year and i
need everybody to vote
i don't care i mean i might care but i'm
not going to tell you who to vote for i
just need you to vote your conscience
and vote
but when you vote we also have to think
about this idea of gerrymandering
gerrymandering is the practice where
they draw your district
in a way that either makes your vote
less powerful
in the area right so for example if
there's a hundred black people
in in a town and i can and i can put one
black person in each
in each neighborhood each district or
ten in each district then there's no
powerful black vote
right so i'm watering down your vote by
drawing the district in weird ways
because when you look at how districts
are drawn in cities and states they're
not drawing like
straight lines that would make sense
they're drawn sometimes like this
you know right back in the day one was
drawn like a salamander which is why
it's called gerrymandering
and so they draw it so that all the
black people are spread out or all the
poor people are spread out or all
all the italians are spread out or they
make it so that all those people are in
one place like you know what y'all gonna
get this one district y'all gonna get
harlem
y'all gonna get y'all right just one
though right so instead of having to
have an impact in every election
we'll just say there's going to be 10
districts and one is going to be black
one is going to be latinx
and then that way it still lessens the
impact right it's this idea
when you spread it out it's called
cracking when you do it the opposite way
it's called packing
but in each case we're trying to water
down the vote and that's another way of
suppressing our vote because we're
making our vote not matter as much
that's why it's important for everybody
to vote at every election
at every level i love your passion
surrounding voting now we love that you
stuck to the rules we appreciate you
i thank y'all man and more importantly
thank you all for the work y'all are
doing what y'all are doing right now all
three uh
is the work of justice and freedom this
is the work that will make the world
better than we found
it and you all need to be applauded for
this i love you all for this
thank you we love you too thank you so
much
thank you all peace felony
disenfranchising to prevent the victim
felons from voting celebrities like mike
tyson recently chimed in on the matter
though
saying that this election would be his
first time voting he never thought he
could vote because of his felony record
and he's
finally proud to vote and we're so happy
for you mike
yes we are also on big boys radio show
rapper snoop dogg said and i quote for
many years they had me brainwashed
thinking that you couldn't vote because
you had a criminal record
and i think that this next guest is the
perfect guest to talk about this topic
right now hailing from the bx byway
miami that's where he's
calling in from he's here to share his
opinions
on felony disenfranchisement please
welcome to the show
our dear friend fat joe
i just gave you that 106 part joey crack
in the building intro
platinum introduction platinum we know
you got to get to the big big
show in just a little bit but joey thank
you so much for taking time out for us
real first let's just jump into it i
want to know for you in particular
how has your family been impacted by the
criminal justice system when it comes to
voting
wow i have a lot of friends um
voter suppression been happening before
we even knew it was voters
suppression so the minute you get locked
up or something
uh you become not eligible to uh to vote
so now your voice doesn't count so uh
we've been we've been impacted for years
and years and years in the hood
uh with voter suppression now felony
laws do vary
state by state do you think every state
should allow felons to vote
i mean you know from my understanding
uh there's other countries that from the
second you're born
you're eligible to vote once you hit a
certain age so
it's not like you need a voting card you
don't need an id
you don't need a registration you don't
you know it's your right
as being the citizen of that country so
everyone should have the
right to be able to vote and be heard
because we're all americans even though
some people
may have made a mistake in their life
you know and i also believe that people
can change
i believe that uh people can change who
i
who i was when i was 18 20 25
is not who i am now so i think that
you know we should never we shouldn't
always be penalized
for something we've done in the past
absolutely so how does it make you feel
to hear about snoop dogg and mike
tyson's
excitement to vote for the first time
i'm glad
snoop dogg is able to vote uh who's a
very very prominent figure in our
community
who's been telling everybody to register
to vote who's been there
and i am mike tyson you know that's an
american icon
that's exactly what i mean you may be
able to make a mistake or you would like
but that doesn't define you you can
change so i'm proud of both of them
do you know a lot of people that are
dealing with that right
well my sister remy boss she's not
allowed to vote
because she did that time and remy
is really aware of politics and also
her surrounding and she would love to
vote
and can't vote so it's like
you know what you know we deal with that
i got so many friends that's been locked
up that's not able to vote
i mean unfortunately we've been almost
brainwashed to believe
that we don't deserve the right to vote
because
somebody got locked up with this jail
time you know it's pretty much
uh a brainwashed job
yes thank you so much for that yes thank
you fat joe so much for joining us today
um you are super helpful super
informative and i know everyone is
grateful for you
being here so thank you okay thank you
so much
tell everybody to get out there register
to vote
and actually go vote and we got to go
out there
and vote as one i guys
so guys here's one thing something that
we didn't think about are the elections
in our home towns and
how they change our everyday lives we
all have to show up for a presidential
election
and we must be proactive in our local
elections and guys i'm so excited
because as we're talking about the
importance of
local voting this next woman she knows
all about elections and most importantly
the local
level of things please welcome alicia
johnson to the show
thank you thanks for having me i'm so
excited that you're here because i
stress so much to people guys it's not
only about the presidential vote
it's about who you're electing into
office who you're electing in
to be a judge our share of everything
because
please knock it into s dome right now
the
importance of the local vote
you know i'm so glad you said that and
my background
is in presidential politics but all of
the issues that i have fought for
my entire career and actually my entire
life from reproductive health care
civil rights voting rights racial
justice
those are literally impacted at the
local level i talk to college students
all the time and they say you know
i can't see why it's so important for me
to vote in the presidential election
because things aren't changing and i
flip that on them and ask them
what's your number one issue when i ask
the question at houston students at
morehouse college they
they mentioned criminal justice reform
because they were young black men and i
said well listen
there is an ability to elect over 2 400
attorneys at the state and district
level who are
managing the cases that we are all
protesting against and
and the interesting thing about that is
those 2400
elected prosecutor attorney position
only 25
25 of them are black women only a small
percentage of them are black people and
so we have the ability to
change politics and policies at the
local level
that will impact us within that year of
us voting
if we get out in these local elections
so yes the top of the ticket is
important
but it's really those local elections
where we're talking about judges
attorneys superintendents uh city
councils school board members you name
it those are all electrical positions
that really
impact our day-to-day life but
propositions as well
people ignore propositions and it's like
yo
these are like rights that we're voting
into office and we don't even know um
it baffles my mind when we complain
about something but it's like we didn't
go and vote for it because
hey it's every two years for our local
representatives it's not every four
years
at a time right right i mean we think
about the things that
folks really care about from legalizing
marijuana
that unfortunately without it being
legalized has over incarcerated so many
black and brown folks you think about
legalizing same-sex marriage all of
these started out as state propositions
within california
and oregon in colorado and that
went all the way up to the federal level
for some and we're still fighting for
federal policy to legalize marijuana
across the country right and so to your
point i'm glad you brought this
up a lot of we start with propositions
there are
districts that are putting propositions
around how you can
you know incarcerate people or the
rights that they have restored when they
get out of
a jail prison and so that's so important
for people to pay attention to the
propositions that are on their ballots
yes thank you so much for that
explanation so in past elections how are
you able to bridge the gap
between local voters and state
candidates
you know i think we need to a lot of
this is storytelling so i've been
fortunate to work on president obama's
election i've worked with hillary
clinton's campaign i worked on senator
liv the foreign presidential campaign
right now i'm currently working with
the joe biden campaign and to be honest
while these are national presidential
campaigns
the way that we've been able to move
voters to
be enthusiastic and to engage is by
local stores local community leaders
oftentimes in the work that i do
i get asked we bring influencers and
celebrities from people with millions
and hundred thousand
followers to include in the campaign but
what i really find
is those local community leaders are the
prospect voices so
the the church first lady or the
hairdresser at our favorite salon or the
barber or our favorite dish jockey
you seem to be better messenger for
voters to get them engaged on the issues
that
that pertain to them and i'm not just
talking about them being out here
talking about
the candidate that they that they love
they're holding round tables as small
black business owners they are having
conversations about access to health
care
and what a law means for them as they
are on their entrepreneurship journey or
they just graduated from college
and may not have the job that they want
and so these local
influential people who have the trusted
voice of the community who have the
authentic stories
that are really how we bridge that gap
and bring people
along the process i love that you guys
because people around you if you see
them doing it you're more likely to do
it and follow their footsteps so that
makes
perfect sense how does 1063
west broad inform people about the
issues that affect black and brown
communities
yeah so we work with different companies
and organizations
and major brands on issues that they
care about for me
like you have to be committed to racial
justice you have to be committed to
gender equity
and pro-choice causes and often times we
take
big brands who say i want to do more for
people of color i want to do more for
women of color
and i want to connect them on certain
issues and sometimes they'll say
i don't want to be political and i said
well actually
in our country the person has become
political and you actually have to take
a side if we look at the current
occupant in the white house
he's taken aside and so therefore we
have to think aside and so
we try to tap into the culture leaders
and the creators whether it's the
clothing brands whether it's the story
storylines that we're seeing in tv in
film whether it's technology and the
latest trend that's happening on twitter
how are we tapping into that authentic
engagement to these culture moments
around critical issues related to people
of color and so
i i love what so many organizations are
doing we were talking about the verses
challenge before we all got on here
right now they're using that platform to
talk about voting you know we're seeing
that award shows are talking about
voting they're bringing in the
critical elements of our right to
exercise our right to vote and so
that is what 1063 is doing uh working
with different candidates and getting
them on platforms with
entertainers with enforcers people who
you know
i'll hear people who say oh you got
so-and-so to do this instagram live with
this person and i didn't even know they
were politically engaged but
that is a way to marry two people who
carry who care about a certain issue but
come from different industries different
backgrounds together
to really engage with folks one of the
things that i love that the biting
campaign
recently did was we put obama president
obama in the chamber
like talk about getting to the culture
we went to the chamber what happened
there's 20 million followers i heard on
the same room
one example alexis we're all always
together
we just want to thank you for taking the
time to share your passion with us about
voting
and how important it is not just right
now in this election
but every election so thank you so much
for saying
thank you thank you so much thank you
yes super important also there's a
direct connection between voting and the
local elections and getting our needs
met on a national level it's all
important and i'm really happy that we
had alyssia
here to break it all down for us our
next guest knows all about community
engagement
she's the ceo of wing and she was also
the former national youth
vote director and we actually go way way
way back
please welcome felicia butterfield hey
hey hey mama we love you
oh my gosh girl i'm gonna fan out
because if there's two girls
that i fan out about it's felicia and
rihanna those are like
up there hey felicia thank you for being
here
thanks for having me i'm so glad you're
here you being
the daughter of a u.s congressman we
love
mr butterfield over there i want to know
for you
i always stress the importance of local
voting in your own towns in your own
community
how important is it to tell people to be
informed not only
in the big ballot but also on a local
level as well
um it's crazy roxy and eunice and and
freddie too that
i grew up in a small town in north
carolina called wilson rural part of
the south southern state that typically
always votes red
right so growing up in the south in the
80s and 90s
both of my parents were elected
officials my dad as you mentioned is the
united states congressman but started
as a judge in in the local courts there
and then my mom is a north carolina
state representative and long story
short
i remember as early as five years old
understanding the importance of thinking
globally
in the work that you want to do maybe in
the dreams that you have in life but
having to operate locally and so for me
i think it's important to focus so much
on who we're electing
um as the next president of the united
states but also thinking about the state
elections and the local elections to
make sure that you're getting good
people
in those seats i've seen great
politicians they exist
they're out there my parents are two
examples of that and so i really believe
it's less about politics and more about
just getting the right people in office
they're going to fight for you
not just the big national ones with
lights and camera actions but the real
work is done
locally getting free like if you think
about you know the bridge that may be
broken in your
small town or you know the things that
you have to do locally
in your you know right in the
neighborhoods that you live in
that happens at the local level and so
you know again it's important to think
about who's going to be the next
president of the united states
but you also have to make sure that
you're really voting down ballot based
on
the people that really care about the
issues that matter to you every single
day
right absolutely so you clearly come
from a long line of powerful political
figures and you've also done a lot of
this work
in your life as well so i just want to
know like how do you use your past
experiences to encourage others to get
involved in their communities
you know i think freddie the first thing
is you know for any young person
watching
i definitely was one of those people
when i was young like hey
does my vote really matter do i really
even want to work in politics because
both of my parents worked in politics
and so
you know i questioned those things when
i was younger like does my vote really
count
should i really be a part of this and i
can honestly say it does
and so when i worked for president obama
as a national youth boat director
i was able to witness firsthand as i
traveled across the country
on the power of young people the power
in your voice
the power in your vote and so if ever
there is a time for you to activate your
vote it is
right now um and young people have the
power so you know i think that we think
that
you know we don't have as much power the
younger that we are but you actually
have all the power because you're the
future and you're the now and so
you know if it's your first time voting
um or if you're voting
for the first time in a long time just
remember that you know when it feels
hard
when it feels too big or too impossible
you actually do have the power
and so make sure that you use it on
november 3rd and and leading up to the
election
well that's it in a nutshell right there
thank you lucia we so appreciate
you coming to sit and talk with us and i
hope that every young person hears your
words because you actually work with the
youth vote so you know
what it takes to get them to vote and we
just want to thank you for coming and
sitting with us today
it must be time for another hip-hop
summit or something i feel one coming on
listen i
do remember we traveled all over this
country together
free roxie freddie it was powerful and
it was magical and so
thank you ladies for what you're doing
here um because i think it's so
important now with coven and everything
to take it digital
right so we're in a virtual world right
now and the work don't stop
and so it never works don't stop and if
this is somebody that's
okay we need a digital master classes it
is felicia butterfield
thank you again so much we really
appreciate you joining in with us so
thank you so much we love you bye-bye i
love you ladies
november 3rd is the big day you're
registered to vote
you know all the candidates and what
they stand for
watch the debates you know what issues
are important to you
and your family it's time to make your
choice
yes i'm so ready to vote it's been time
it's been such a long time coming i'm so
excited
um but we have some questions that we
want to answer for you guys so how
should you prepare
before you hit the polls first choose
how you plan to vote
next know your local election dates and
deadlines
next wear bipartisan clothing and then
finally stay in line just stay in line
commit i know it could be long but it
will be very much worth it if you just
stay in line and cast your vote exactly
act like it's a pair of new jordans that
is coming out on release day
until you get that purchase all right
don't go anywhere until
you vote but let's be real the pandemic
is affecting this year's election
and that shouldn't stop you from casting
your vote there are
many opinions available to us to make
sure that we are
safe on election day all right so we're
jumping back into buzzfeed world for a
second buzzfeed news reporter hayes
brown
is going to tell us about voting on
election day and what to expect after
welcome home
brown hi thanks for having me you guys
hi hey hoodie
so hey let's jump right in what safety
measures can voters take on election day
well if you are voting in person on
election day then
safety measures like you would going to
the grocery store to be honest
you want to be wearing a mask you want
to be socially distantly as much as
possible
and you want to be aware of the fact
that we are still in a pandemic
and that shouldn't run up against your
right to vote
so if you're going out to the following
location know where you're going
have a location at well at hand in your
brain what location you're going to
try and be in and out as best you can i
know that for a lot of people that's not
the case which is very unfortunate
i know it's going to be hard for a lot
of people because the lines are probably
going to be pretty long this year a lot
of people want to vote
but still while you're waiting in line
you're right to vote
your right to stay in line until the
polls close until you've had the right
to vote
so do your best to keep that social
distance to keep that six feet apart
from people
around you even as the line seems
infinite
thank you hayes now in the past with
elections it always seems like
we're sitting at the tv and we're
waiting for that
result to come through it's a little
different this year right how long is it
really going to take
to count all the votes realistically we
might
have a case where the president declares
victory just based on the returns from
november 3rd
but we're not going to know for sure
who has won unless it's a complete
blowout
uh in the electoral college until much
later
let's talk about the chain in command if
there will be a tune in command what
happens after we get those results
and the transition because it's not
automatic once we know who the winner is
and in this case
it's going to take a minute for us to
really get those results
yeah it is and so here's where it gets
tricky because election law
unfortunately is not very clear in a lot
of ways hopefully
this runs normal run smooth we know
within a couple of weeks who has won
each of the electors
uh both candidates agreed yep that is
the correct result
the electoral college meets no drama
they vote
we have a president sworn in for a new
term come january
but like i said this is a weird year so
there's a lot
up in the air and a lot to look out for
right so you're wearing
after election day that it's not over
you were like
i hope it won't move then hopefully you
know i'm like have you been
funny with us
i know i'm concerned
i am concerned but i want everyone to
know
what sort of processes are in place
right now so that
if things do look weird they can say all
right
i know what is happening right now and
here's if i
should or should not be really freaking
out right now
right deep breaths everybody it's gonna
be all right we're all in this together
of the things i can say is nancy pelosi
speaker of the house if we do get to the
last situation she sent out a letter
to her democratic colleagues saying look
we gotta run up the vote this year then
we can't let any of our slide we have to
make sure that we win an even bigger
majority in the house to make sure
if we do have to make this decision that
we have more uh states behind us
but at the same time the trump campaign
and the gop
the rnc they're filing the they're
prepared to file
a lot of motions after election day to
help decide
which ballot should be counted and which
shouldn't so
it's going to be tense let's put it that
way it's going to be
10.
hey thank you so much for being with us
today we appreciate
all the information all the gems that
you just dropped on us thank you so much
glad to do super informative and also we
would love to spotlight the organization
that brought us all together
that's right let's go ahead and say it
and still i
vote and still i vote guys it's a group
that takes action against
all forms of voter suppression and
empowers communities across the nation
to stay
active in the election our final guest
is a part of the campaign and still i
vote
please welcome lee chapman we're so
happy to have you here today lee we've
been talking
about voting and youth and rights and we
want to know a little bit more about
the campaign that you're working with
and still i vote
thank you so much for having me so and
still i vote is actually a project of
the leadership conference on civil and
human rights and we're the nation's
largest and oldest civil rights
coalition
we've actually been around for 70 years
and we've been at the front lines of
every major civil rights battle from the
passage of the civil rights act
and the voting rights act of 1965. so we
knew because
of voter suppression in our country that
we needed to have a campaign
to shine a spotlight on voter
suppression and really mobilize people
to take action
so that's why we launched and still i
vote we launched it earlier this year
in selma alabama actually on the edmund
pettus bridge where
late congressman john lewis you know was
beaten and bloodied
for um civil rights and for voting
rights in our country
and so that was such an important moment
for us
and we knew that voter suppression was
alive and well in in 2020.
you just have to look at the 2018
election look at georgia
where there were massive voter purges
there were pulling place closures in
black neighborhoods there were
you know long lines of five to seven
hours
for black people to vote so we launched
this campaign and then covet 19
hit which is just another barrier to the
ballot that that people are facing
especially
um black and brown voters and and you
speak about the honorable john lewis and
i know he'd be smiling upon you right
now
knowing that we're still fighting
against voter suppression and that's one
of the messages that we've been
kind of pounding and pounding and
pounding on people to go
out there and know what your rights are
to go vote but i do want to also shed
light
on the heroes act and it's important can
you shine some light on that for me
please
sure so when covid19 hit we knew that
this was going to be a challenge
for voting rights in our country and you
know election officials needed
additional funds and resources so voters
could
cast their votes safely this year
without a worry or concern of
contracting covet 19.
so we were pushing and advocating for
congress to provide more funding so
states could have
ppe so they could have more poll workers
so they could have
more vote-by-mail ballots and more early
voting days so people could safely
social distance and cast their ballot
but unfortunately because of
partisanship
in our congress that bill was actually
blocked by the senate
it passed the house in may and um
it had over 3.6 billion dollars in
funding for elections
but senator mcconnell actually blocked
it and it's been sitting on his desk
for over 140 days without action which
is
really a shame because we should want to
have a democracy where more people can
participate
you know our elected leader should be
doing everything that they can
to provide more resources for voters to
safely cast their ballot in the middle
of a pandemic
and it's unfortunate that you know some
elected leaders just don't see that
so advocates like the leadership
conference our partners we've been
litigating
we've been advocating and also private
businesses have actually stepped up to
the plate
and have provided that critical funding
that we need
for states to operate safe elections
this year yes thank you so much
so i i do want to just ask a follow-up
because i do feel like
people in general it's like people who
are eligible eligible to vote in america
we a lot of times feel like no matter
what we do if something gets to an
election official's desk
and there's legislation that we that
needs to be signed and he's just letting
it sit there like what can we do
as citizens to really help to push that
initiative forward when it feels
hopeless in that way
you know i think it's really important
that we hold our elected leaders
accountable
and you know if they're not doing what
we want them to do in congress or in
state legislatures or in the city hall
we need to vote them out you know you
have to make sure you're
you're registering to vote make sure you
vote in every election from local
election to state elections to federal
elections because
what they do have impact on on our
everyday lives
so um that's one thing that we try to
encourage is that people really
make that connection on the policies
that we want to see whether it's ending
police brutality or having better
education or
better health care for our our families
you know it all starts with making sure
that we elect
leaders that represent our interests
yeah and so that goes back to
sort of what we've been discussing
throughout all of these episodes is just
that it's really important to
vote make your voice heard from a
smaller local level all the way up to
nationwide and so with that said i would
love to welcome to the voting rights
program
and i'd like to talk a little bit about
how you know even after november 3rd how
is that program going to stay active
sure so depending on how the election
shakes out we do not know yet
but if congress does become more
progressive and more open to
pro-democracy legislation
then we have a real opportunity to pass
some impactful bills
so the leadership conference we have two
main priorities when it comes to voting
um one is called the for the people act
and that's a huge
massive voting rights bill that would
end
felony disenfranchisement you know we
hear that a lot of people with felony
convictions are blocked from
the ballot so this would end that
practice nationwide
it would have automatic voter
registration nationwide same-day voter
registration nationwide
i mean it would do so much just to
transform our voting system
and it's something that's critically
needed so that's one priority another
one
is the voting rights advancement act
which was recently named the john lewis
voting rights advancement act
after he passed away and that bill is
all about restoring the voting rights
act
that was gutted by the supreme court in
2013.
so with that bill states that had a
history
of voting discrimination way back since
the 60s
had to have any voting law or policy
approved by the federal government
before they could
put into place to make sure it didn't
discriminate against voters of color
and in 2013 the supreme court basically
just
rubber stamped voter suppression um with
this case shelby county versus holder so
we've been working since then for seven
years to make sure that we're restoring
the voting rights act
so we can stop voter suppression so we
can stop strict voter id laws
um voter purges and massive polling
place closures that we know lead to
these five to seven hour long
long lines in majority neighborhoods of
people of color
great there's so much that we can do
with the polls whether it's helping
somebody get there
whether it's bringing water to support
people and we really salute
and fill our vote for all the work
they're doing to make sure people get
out
we want to thank you for joining us lee
thank you so much for having me
i hope you guys know and see how
determined we
are to give you all the information you
need to cast a vote
properly and also to know the issues
that you're passing your vote for
all i know is if you need more
information go to amsterd.org
and you'll find everything you need
everything trust me we want to thank our
guests that joined us today and thank
you so much
and for myself freddie and free that is
it for our series we hope you guys are
armed and ready to go out there and go
and
vote uh tell a friend gotta go
yes we have to go we don't have time to
play y'all actually we're going to go
right now y'all i think
the cast bye-bye see you later
you